My husband doesn't cook,
but he does bake
and he's really good at it. And lately
I've just been violently craving cookie dough,
so he made me his famous recipe.
He started by combining some white and brown sugar
with some room temperature butter and an egg.
Give that really good mix
until everything was really smooth.
He gets very,
very specific with his measurements,
so he always has to make sure everything is level
and perfectly measured out.
Added some vanilla
baking powder
and flaky sea salt
and then some flour
and mix that until everything was incorporated
before he added in some more flour and oats.
I don't really like chocolate chips
so he only added a few
so that would be really easy
for me to just pick them out.
This is the best cookie dough recipe that I've
ever tasted,
so obviously we had to try it.
And yes, it was as good as we both remembered it
cause we haven't made this in a while.
Then he plated me up some cookie dough
before he formed his into little balls
and place them on a baking sheet to bake.
We pop them in the oven for about eight minutes at 400
and then transfer them over to a wire rack to cool.
I also made some homemade caramel sauce
that we drizzled over a few of them.